one of basketballs brightest young stars
is about to make his big debut but not
on the court the NBA has entered a
sponsorship deal with a 15 year old
entrepreneur his name is moziah bridges
the agreement gives his company's Moe's
bows like that name the right to use the
NBA logos on its custom-designed bowties
David Wagner met the teen and his mama
in Memphis Tennessee to see how his
fashion sense led to some big big bucks
here on the historic Beale Street
birthplace of the Blues moziah bridges
also known as mo is making a sales call
dress to the nines with his signature
briefcase in hand this teenage talat has
arrived to showcase his latest designs
with a style mo says he inherited from
his dad what do you think when you see a
well-dressed man well I think that means
about something he has a great life he
is very stylish so mo your dad would get
dressed I mean would he I mean was he
always so right now always be dressed he
would go to McDonald's into three pieces
it's a funny story Fort Rebecca Morris
who is Moe's business manager and his
mom I'd say mo go and get dressed and -
he would come completely dressed in a
suit and tie and in my mind it was his
church clothes and it did make sense but
in the last minute I'm just like all
right fine let's go how come yours looks
like that and Mama's because you're a
new beginner Mo's bows began when at the
age of nine this budding fashion
designer wanted to make his own bow ties
in terms of training he didn't have to
go very far
I had my grandma and she helped me so
and she helped me so my first bow tie
and I'm so thankful her name is Helen
Galloway she stopped by during our
interview I am so proud the company
started to catch on after an appearance
on shark tank or moziah bridges an 11
year old fashion designer with a
handmade
toy business the reality-show that makes
her breaks new businesses who drives who
here in just six years the company has
surged in popularity most keen business
sense even earned him a trip to the
White House he's very courageous he's
very confident sometimes where there's a
thin line between cocky and confident we
have to shake them by the both sides and
make sure he understands the importance
of it we have all these bow ties of
course we had the NBA ties this year
most signed a seven-figure deal to
supply bowties to every team in the NBA
but at five foot ten inches the game
being played at this house is how to
keep him fashionably dressed and you
understand that right he fusses I mean
he kind of pushes back on it and then he
and he just has expensive things he's
always had expensive tastes my mom
always taught me day it's important to
give back with all of its success Mo's
bows remains a part of the Memphis
community giving money to local
charities and taking care of the
customers who often drop by his house
unannounced makes the decision on how
the money spent you're a single woman
running a business that is exploding
arguably yeah it's got to feel good it
feels really good what's even more
important to me is that he's defying the
odds of what a fashion designer looks
like I mean he's been a Neiman Marcus
and and Bloomingdale's with all these
you know designers who are older white
men mo a young african-american man from
Memphis Tennessee are doing amazing
things at 15 years old
what has this young man taught you he
has taught me a lot about parenting and
I tell him all the dot all the time I'm
glad that God chose me to be his to be
his mom and if we if they were to put us
all in and I had to scramble around and
pick another kid I still pick you
while Moe's bows may bear his name mom
jamika is always a bowties length away
for CBS this morning
David beg no Memphis Tennessee well mom
Tamika I was just gonna say not all of
her Vlad his fashion sense but also
she's a great mom yes fostering his
passions yeah and look what he's doing
trying to get one are you gonna get with
you I would yeah couple of bills I do
want I'll take a Buffalo Bills one yeah
sure he's making them yeah you better
and I'm just getting started that's
what's so great about it Nora this get
this mo is just getting started
David with another great three great
delivers once again